[Music]
in the last few days senator Cory Booker
and Kamla Harris both endorsed Joe Biden
for president they had no shortage of a
few civ prize for Joe Biden watch I am
with great enthusiasm I'm going to
endorse Joe Biden for President of the
United States we need a leader who
really does care about the people and
who can therefore unify the people and I
believe Joe can do that our divisions as
a country is our weakness we need the
candidate that can best unify all of us
and that is Joe Biden now people who
just got here from Botswana or Malaysia
or don't speak English may have been
impressed by those endorsements but for
those of us with a VCR or a DVR they
didn't quite make sense it was less than
a year ago that Cory Booker was whining
that Biden wouldn't be a disastrous
nominee who would divide the party watch
there's a lot of people who are
concerned about Joe Biden's ability to
carry the ball all the way across the
end line without fumbling and I think
that Castro has some really legitimate
concerns there was a lot of moments
where a number of us were looking at a
soror stage when he tends to go on
sometimes at one point he's talking
about people in communities like mine
listening to record players but there
are definitely moments where you listen
to Joe Biden and you just wonder so what
did Cory Booker just say you know
exactly what he just said he said Joe
Biden's senile he's totally out of it he
can't carry the ball because he's too
old he's not capable of being president
that's what he just said in that tape
Kamla Harris meanwhile said that Biden
was racist I'm gonna now direct this at
Vice President Biden I do not believe
you are a racist but you also worked
with them to oppose busing and you know
there was a little girl in California
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bused to school every day and that
little girl was me so she's for busing
now actually she's not for busing no one
was ever for busing everyone hated
busing
particularly black parents but whatever
she was still calling Biden racist I'm
not calling you racist racist so what
happened
he was senile he was a bigot and now he
must be President well the answer of
course is it was all a sham Harris never
really meant it like most claims of
racism you hear in politics it was
totally fake and totally transactional
mark Stein is an author and a columnist
he joins us tonight so why not just say
in their endorsements look the guy's
senile and he's a bigot but I'm for him
anyway yeah that's that's basically what
they're signing on to the little girl on
the bus as senator Harris described
herself is now on Joe Biden's bus and
whether that's a school district anyone
wants to be driven to remains remains to
be seen it's one where as Cory Booker
pointed out crazy Uncle Joe and he's not
sniffing your hair is sneaking into your
bedroom and putting record players on
all night in which to indoctrinate you
the fact is he's actually gotten worse
since Cory Booker said that what we're
seeing is something quite extraordinary
is see is his rival presidential
candidates are basically now signing on
to a dead husk of a candidate in the
interests of so-called unity I take it
they've all been promised the vice
presidential slot Amy Klobuchar gave it
away today but I think Kamala and and
Cory have been promised it too and God
knows if anybody could use seven or
eight vice-presidential running mates
it's it's Joe Biden but we're seeing
something extraordinary here you know
Trump Trump was the anti the anti
conventional candidate he had no minders
he was all candid at no minders this
campaign now is all minders and no
candidate he's got all these so-called
surrogates now who've endorsed him but
at that they're endorsing something that
isn't there and the question then
becomes who is the there that they're
planning on actually running this show
it's the weird
presidential selection that has been
seen in modern times this well they're
all home health aides they're all nurses
in effect I mean is there anything that
Camel at Harris won't say I mean when
they said to her look can't my Harris
you got to endorse the guy do you think
she even said oh but I called him a
racist I can't cuz now racism doesn't
matter I mean or did she forgot did she
forget that she even said that no racism
is just a bit of chitchat on one side of
the political divide so that as you know
if you're the governor of Virginia and
you're capering around in blackface what
the hell that was just a youthful
indiscretion
it's a youthful indiscretion when Justin
Trudeau is doing it in early middle age
then on the other side these things
destroy your career so we we live in an
age where every morning you wake up and
people with 50-year careers are being
vaporized and then and then on the other
side on the Democrat side if it's one of
your own hey you racist you supported
busing that's just a little bit of light
social chitchat
before you start promising everybody
Medicare for all or open borders Charlie
Rose must be wondering how you can get
back in the game tonight
I would think marks a great to see you
thank you thanks a lot Tucker